what three nba players would be the best  salesman i got for luca lucas sells  anything that guy is so street smart you  have no idea you'll see a lot of really  really cool tech stuff that he helped  engineer literally that is going to be  really cool jordan obviously with  jordan's michael is great at what he  does there theo pinson he did this sales  thing i'm like deal come on you're a  good salesperson let me give you some  hints and so i think he's got that  potential to be really good spencer too  spencer dinwiddie yeah yeah he's a  hustler and he already kind of does that  like he's  like fine nancy and doing all these like  innovative yeah he's smart so he's  learned how to pull all the pieces  together to leverage his brand and he  digs in he doesn't jump from one thing  to the next thing which is good